are in the office
my throat is not so great i have to be
honest i woke up not feeling that great
and uh
canada was playing us on television and
and i was supposed to go and play hockey
and i wasn't feeling well
and i thought i'll just watch the hockey
and i won't play hockey but i just
couldn't let my guys down my teammates
so i went off and played hockey but i've
got the game recorded
and i know the result so when i go home
i'm going to watch it knowing that
nothing bad can happen uh but today you
know i took a bit of a break from korean
while driving to the hockey rink and
then driving back i was listening to
russian for two reasons first of all
there's these tragic events in
in the ukraine and i wanted to get some
kind of a local perspective on it and
second of all i thought i would uh you
know have a discussion uh with kalina in
russian where we talk about the
challenge and stuff like that but it was
shot down everyone here thought that was
a
bad idea
we were wondering how that tied in with
the 90-day challenge
if you're watching
uh every video in english and then all
of a sudden there's a video in a rush
and i guess if we subtitled it might
have been okay but that would have been
a lot of work for galena
uh
that's the theme here is that and so i
was going to raise the subject because
people say well you're learning another
language and yet you could work on
improving i could work on improving my
russian for sure but i have found that
over the years
like my 90-day challenge i'm working on
korean
and so my russian is going to suffer my
check and some of my weaker languages
call it are going to suffer
in the short term
but i know from experience that when i
go back to them like if i were to go and
have a week of russian my russian would
be stronger than ever and it's very
interesting this phenomenon i had the
same experience with other languages if
i studied like i lived in japan for nine
years
when i came back here and did a bit of
chinese my chinese was better than ever
uh
because learning more languages actually
makes your brain more language fit i
have no
um scientific proof of this so i would
encourage you like i know alex he's
stuck on korean you've got to get out of
that
to improve your korean come on
i know
sacrifice
your english which is already
99
you know will even improve yeah
hopefully no it will because first of
all vocabulary wise you'll get a
different sense of the meaning of words
i find that my french improve my english
so i always feel that studying a variety
of languages even though i say you can't
study three at once
but you'll go through a six month period
with one it improves you honestly in
that language
but also in the others
i would say even studying italian
after probably the language i studied
most recently was french
prior to the italian and you see stuff
in italian that reminds you of stuff
that you saw in french and it reinforces
what you see in french never mind what
you're seeing in italian now so that
that just that additional exposure to
the same sort of concepts or
structures
uh definitely
has an impact it just it's just more
reinforcement what's very good about
learning uh either spanish or italian
is that there the feminine masculine is
much clearer
in most cases a word that ends in always
masculine and a word that ends in a is
feminine so whenever i wonder about a
word in french for example
vocabulary
many words in french that end in an e
are feminine but i know that vocabulary
in spanish ends in an o so i know my
brain is quickly processing that so and
you know because in french it's much
more difficult because you've got all
kinds of words that m and e that are are
masculine like look we'll give you there
so that's our thing today but i suggest
that everyone is on a 90-day challenge
stay on one language for the whole
challenge
but then and we are going to have more
challenges right lots of people are
asking more challenges yeah we should do
something we should
okay
that's all for today
happy weekend yes happy weekend right